all we knew is that
the books themselves have a massive very
supportive fan base and have since its
release and so many people grew up
reading those books so that and and that
there was a great degree of anticipation
on the films as a result of that but
then again at the end of the day we had
no idea of knowing and the impact was
the impact and
it was kind of way bigger than all of us
could have imagined i suppose
[Music]
the lord of the rings trilogy it was the
summer of 1997.
it was harry knowles who ran
in at cool news
of the time
who then
told me the next day hey man you see
that about peter jackson he's making
lord of the rings trilogy
and i remember really specifically
feeling
that that made so much sense i'd seen
heavenly creatures
and i had seen the frighteners
but it was heavenly creatures
specifically that that stood out to me
as being a
kind of incredible
it's not a one-to-one comp but there's
so much in heavenly creatures that
establishes
what he's capable of as a filmmaker and
marrying the notion of of a fantasy
realm with an emotional honesty and
depth and i just remember thinking oh my
god peter jackson that is such an
incredible inspired idea
and i'd not i'd not read lord of the
rings but i'd read the hobbits i was
certainly familiar with middle earth and
the kind of you of of tolkien and what
that was about
so just you know
marrying those two ideas in my head just
made so much sense um and i remember at
the time
that harry was like you should you
should be frodo i thought
that would be great you know
and i remember my agent calling me at
the time and saying they're casting for
lord of the rings um
you should go in for frodo and i was
like oh yes i'd love to
um but you can't read the script you
have to go into the casting office to
read the script they're not giving the
script out i was like okay so i remember
i went to victoria burroughs casting
office and i sat in an office by myself
for two hours and read the script for
the fellowship of the ring i'll never
forget that and driving home and i was
so immersed in the world
it was so
palpable and life-like it really kind of
came to life off of the page so i'd
never made my own audition tape before
and this is long before the time when
that was common so it was long before
that and i just i just had this impulse
partially because i was a little nervous
second
i just didn't want to go into a white
room and do it that way i was like i
gotta do something different
so
uh
was going to a vocal coach or a dialect
coach for the dialect and then
enlisted some friends
um including george wang who's a writer
filmmaker we went out to
the woods i think in griffith park and
shot
two of the audition sequences there and
then one at my house and it's sort of
like each there's three scenes each one
was sort of a different
aspect of frodo along the journey the
last one being kind of like quite
deeply affected by the ring ring is mine
we went to the miramax offices that
night when miramax was still a thing and
cut the scenes together and then i took
that tape
it's output to vhs
i took that tape
to
victoria burrow's office and then they
fedexed it to peter i got a call from
peter himself which was amazing
uh totally mind-blowing
and you know the adventure and
opportunity of a lifetime
what must i do
you must leave and leave quickly
where where do i go get out of the
shower
[Music]
going into it
there was absolutely an understanding of
the enormity of the adventure and the
fact that we were literally going to
live in new zealand for a very long time
um
which was thrilling
i think we should get off the road
what was that feeling um stepping into
the shoes the the hobbit feet of frodo
for the first time
thrilling
really exciting but i have to say that
yeah i mean there was a buzz of course
there was a buzz of excitement of now
we're actually shooting here we go but
we had
had time very well spent prior two
months
two months and change prior to actually
shooting of
the team getting to know each other
rehearsals talking about the characters
um
sword lessons horseback riding lessons
in some cases rowing lessons dialect
coach
just this program of preparation
that we were all a part of kind of like
this boot camp and
by the time we started shooting we were
so entrenched
with each other
and the film that we were making that
it it what it
yes it was a buzzy day and super
exciting and like oh my god we're really
doing it
for sure but there was also this like we
were in already in in a great way you
know we had spent so much time already
locked arm and arm you know as a
fellowship heading on this journey
together they had made these boots
because the part of the thing it was
very much in the infancy of the internet
as it pertains to
um eyes being on productions and spies
and so on and so forth but it was
happening
and there were people trying to get
photos of us in costume and so they were
trying to dissuade that from happening
and they had us in big robes um you know
in between shots and and whenever we
were traveling from place to place in
case we were photographed and they had
these big boots in part to protect the
feet themselves but also to like cover
them up and there were these big boots
that we could put on and cover our feet
uh walking around
and so yeah i just remember that like
walking from our trailer and these big
green like
fabric boots
uh covering our feet and these robes
uh is awesome and you know to start with
that scene too
with the four hobbits was really lovely
[Music]
mary it's vikings hello frodo we'd
already formed a real bond and so
to start with that material which starts
really fun
[Music]
we're falling down this hill after
and pippen are running away from farmer
maggots field after stealing a bunch of
vegetables
and then we fall and it's the sort of
hilarious moment and then the
realization that we're on the road we
have to get off the road get off the
road
quick
and the sense that something's coming
was just a blast and fun to play that
material first it was sort of a perfect
thing to start with
we're about to hit the 20th anniversary
of the release of fellowship of the ring
this december and
it's definitely been on our minds um and
weirdly the memories that stick out the
most are not the ones that are the most
expected so like obviously getting in a
helicopter and flying to the top of the
mountain is an incredible thing and
there are so many of those grand
memories
but the memories that stick out the most
are the sort of mundane things it's like
the three hours between setups where
we'd go to each other's trailers and
take a nap or play video games or
after working a 16 17 hour day still
wanting to go out for dinner um
going for brunch on weekends you know
renting videos at aerostreet video store
and like
it's it's the life of it because it was
our lives you know it
and it was funny coming back from that
it was so difficult to articulate to
people what it was like to have made it
and be there and then the the the sort
of subsequent time so there was 16
months of principal photography we shot
all three films at once
and then each i remember getting the
call for the pickups and that was a
unique thing it wasn't pre-planned
so it was like a couple months after we
got home got the call like hey so we're
gonna have everyone come back
and we're like yeah great it wasn't over
because we'd gone through this whole
process of saying goodbye
you know which was a really look it's
hard enough to say goodbye after a month
two months on a film it was really hard
to say goodbye after 16 months
especially when your life is displaced
you know when you're not home anymore
you are your home is there
so to get to come back for each
subsequent film was a joy um
and yeah
miss new zealand still
[Music]
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
and obviously seen all of michelle
gandre's videos up
up to that point and just
i would have done anything in that film
it wouldn't have mattered prior to that
and certainly post that
that became probably the primary
motivator for me as an actor is just
wanting to work with
creatives that i
that i love and and wanting to be a part
of facilitating whatever it is that
their vision is became kind of the
driving force
behind any decisions that i ever had uh
or could make as it pertains to being an
actor and something is just i just
wanted to be a part of whatever they
were doing um and the script is was
incredible and then the cast they
amassed was amazing and i it was just uh
yeah so fortunate to get to be a part of
that film it still remains
one of my favorite films
regardless of whether i was in it or not
i just think that movie is a masterpiece
it's
it's so emotional
it's it's kind of upsetting jim's
performance in that film is
one of the best of his career i think
still the sort of emotional
vulnerability that he achieved was
really amazing kate winslet getting a
chance to work with kate was such a joy
i've been a fan of her since heavenly
creatures mark ruffalo kirsten who i
knew from growing up a little bit i'd
seen her around just an amazing
uh tom wilkinson too the cast was so rad
yes
can i help you
you mean
can i help you with something
to be in service of
michelle's vision too on a daily basis
and so much of that was in camera
there was one scene that sort of changed
everything for everybody i was i mean i
was always so excited but one scene that
kind of
exemplified what the movie was for the
crew and for the cast
and it's a scene in the film that's a
it's a wanner
so it takes kate and jim from their
house in montauk through a hallway
they'd fashioned like part of that house
into into this actual real practical
hallway of the hospital or the the
doctor's office
he runs into the doctor's office wake me
up
and he sees himself talking to tom
wilkinson the doctor
and so the camera's panning he then like
changed his clothes became the patient
that he's observing camera pans around
and it's back to jim
observing himself and then i'm in the
background like fumbling with some
papers it was this incredible wonder
where two versions of jim exist in the
same shot by way of him having to change
his clothes it was incredible and you
saw it in camera of there's no trickery
it just was and i remember that night
the entire crew went out for drinks for
the first time was the second week and
it was the end of the second week and it
was electric this feeling of we're
making something
incredible and we could all see it for
the first time and it was
it was really really special that was a
great great experience
sin city first off getting to be a part
of that was such a dream
love the graphic novels it's weird the
timing of it i'd read through all of it
and then heard went out to dinner with
robert and he said i'm i'm making sin
city and i was like holy i just read
these books and in my head as i was
reading them i was thinking man it would
be amazing to see this animated because
the artwork is so beautiful and so
specific and so we were out at dinner
and he's like yeah my next project is in
city do you want to see some of it and
he had shot that opening sequence with
josh hartnett out on the roof
the wind rises electric
he'd shot that as a proof of concept
both for
frank miller to prove that he could he
could bring the stories to life in such
a way that would look like the work that
he had drawn
um
and also as a proof of concept to get
the movie made
so i go out to his his car and on his
computer is that scene that he had
already shot and it was like it was a
game changer like holy [ __ ] it you've
done it it's
it is exactly like the comic
and so then
he asked me to audition and my audition
process was to go into
um
he was holding auditions at the four
seasons in l.a
and i went into a hotel room
and i put on glasses and he's like i'm
just going to read passages from the
comic
from the graphic novel and you just
stare at the camera that was my audition
there was no physicality at all
um and i got the role uh obviously what
kind
so i sniff around and see what's buried
it was a joy to be able to work in that
space and then you know we were working
off of the comics the the graphic novel
was the storyboard so every panel of
this of the graphic novel was
was shot and realized so you literally
had the blueprint for the film in the
graphic novel which was such an
incredible and electrifying feeling
because you know it well and you're like
we're shooting that shot in that frame
in that frame
it's impossible nobody can sneak up on
me
i go blind but then frank was also
coming up with new frames
offset
um
and was there very much present to sort
of comment on this is right this is what
kevin would do this is what kevin
wouldn't do it's great amazing
and i shot all of my scenes in two days
because predominantly the movie was shot
against blue or green screen then a few
sets the bar was a set and there were a
couple others but most of it was
a green screen
and mickey rourke had already shot his
scenes so i shot everything with
mickey's stunt double
um
yeah and like did some wire work which
i'd never done so i'm up on wires doing
high kicks and it was dude it was
awesome it was so much fun
and fun to play a villain i'd never
played
a villain or psychopath before uh
certainly not a mute one
wilfred
i think i was
open to tv and certainly open to comedy
i think that was also something that i
was actively looking for was just
something in the comedy space because i
really had not had much experience in
comedy and i was excited about that as a
challenge
and also just being a fan of comedy and
this script just came about and was sent
to me and
i
lost it like the script was the pilot
script was deeply funny
i then researched because i knew that it
was based on a pre-existing series that
was based on a short film from australia
so i watched bits of the original series
and loved it
at how weird and dark it was and wilfred
was this crazy amalgam of
really weird
super funny
also it had the heart you know at the
core it is about a man who might be
losing his grip on reality has some
mental health issues
so there's also something very human
about what's
our approach to
this version of wilfred and it was a joy
it was four years of
uh you know every every year for three
months out of the year we'd have to
laugh um it was really fun
really fun to be a part of that what
schedule are we going through
uh amc
and working at fx was great you know it
felt like we were
these sort of uh we were the rogues
making the weird talking dog show
very nice
some sofas it's impossible to get
comfortable not this one
my favorite part parts of that show the
weirder it got the better it got those
are my favorite episodes where it's like
what the [ __ ] is going on as a joy and
and you know it was endlessly
entertaining
uh to watch jason do what he did that
character is so his creation and and
it it really did allow him to go to so
many different places so from episode to
episode
there was just
there was constant manipulation coming
from that character and it could be so
many things and it was really really
thrilling and [ __ ] hilarious to watch
and to be a part of it was great
and great to be on a part of television
too is it was a different experience for
me i you know
coming from film the pace is a lot
slower on films tv is fast and you know
we were working
six to eight pages a day of dialogue
burning through material really quickly
and i was not used to that pace and i
found it exhilarating so much fun you're
kind of going and there's no waiting
around which i really enjoyed it was fun
it definitely keeps you on your toes
maniac
and this one
once i read it and understood what the
sort of intention behind it was i
recognized that it was very different i
mean it you know
primarily because most of the movie is
in pov sort of reminded me of this great
movie from i think the 60s called
peeping tom which has similar elements
um in pov
so that was really thrilling the fact
that you wouldn't really see the
character um
except for these sort of out-of-body
experiences he has when he kills the his
victims um and in sort of reflections
and mirrors and i thought well that's
really interesting
to play the primary
villain and murderer and not really see
him but also experience what he's doing
through him
was a pretty thrilling idea
i was a fan of of alex alja's first film
high tension um which had a really great
twist at the end uh and so the fact that
alex was a part of it and frank calfoon
was the director
was just this really interesting
creative package
with a very unique approach and again
and what's funny and i remember this
really specifically as well they were
like oh you only need to work for like
i think the proposal was a week to shoot
all of your stuff on camera and then you
don't have to be there
and i went in for a meeting and i was
like
no i i think i need to be there every
day they're like oh would you and i'm
like well i need to be a part of the
decision-making process of of the
operator who is effectively my character
to work out what
he
or she is going to do
to portray the character you know once
we actually got into production we we
all kind of realized how much more
to that process was there than we'd any
of us had anticipated because then
being there every day on set
it became this really interesting
creative process of deconstructing a
scene we would we would always rehearse
it with the cast without the camera
operator and and
maxine who is our dp and primary
operator
would watch
and so we would we would block it like a
regular scene and then maxine would
insert himself and figure out
logistically how that would work with
the camera and then on top of that i
would find ways to get in like with my
arm into frame we also had i had a
double so if it was two hands coming
into frame occasionally one would use
the left and one would use the right
things like that
so it became this really interesting
dance of choreography every day on set
trying to figure out a way
to be a part of it
physically
changing your makeup and hairstyle
didn't fool me
[Music]
you didn't think i'd recognize you
why
because you think i'm stupid
why do you act like i don't exist and
also just kind of semi-directing that
process you know as an actor and
figuring it out it was the most i've
ever like the most intimately i've
worked with a dp before um and it was a
total joy
so it was kind of a part played in in a
in in like three layers because there
was this sort of off-camera aspect
with the dp
and then there was the on-camera aspect
finding these reflection shots and we
found more there were sort of many
scripted
um
reflections in the movie and as we were
going we would just pick them up and see
oh well there's a way to get a
reflection here and a way to see him
here so we did that too so there was a
real sense of discovery on the process
and then
then it was the voice over and i
re-recorded all of the dialogue
in a in a voice-over studio so filled in
breaths and presents in in ways that we
couldn't have thought of at the time
that i was able to sort of dial in
in post and that was
that's sort of where the character came
to life
was in the the voice really because
there's so much of him you don't see it
was a very fun creative process
um i really loved it and the film's
really beautiful actually for i mean for
a gruesome horror movie about a
psychopath uh there is there is real
kind of beauty to it
[Music]
grand piano
the making of that film is incredible it
still
remains one of my favorite experiences
ever making a movie eugenie o'meara is
one of my favorite directors and he's
just a dear friend of mine and we had a
really incredible experience making it
but the the interesting thing about the
the bulk of the film takes place in real
time it's during a
concert a
piano classical performance
both with an orchestra and also solo
piano and it takes place in real time
over that performance the music is baked
into the structure of the movie
[Music]
and so he had also
cut together an animatic of the movie
of of basically like an active
storyboard of of the way that the film
was going to be shot
as it was also cut to the music very
specifically so you know this bar here
the camera does this this bar here it's
on his hands really really specific
which was an incredible
document for me to have in terms of the
preparation to know where i would be at
any given time as it pertains to the
music
but then there was also just the music
which is incredibly complex
even for a classically trained pianist
specifically los angeles which is the un
what is it the unplayable piece
more than it seems emma ever did
holding your hand orchestrating your
return to the stage so
it was a couple things it was like
trying to learn that music very quickly
which was impossible because i didn't
play piano i took lessons when i was
young
but this was like sort of starting from
scratch so there was like some i was
pulling from certainly hand placement
and basic skills
but in terms of the degree that this was
demanding i couldn't play that so
it was it was scary and daunting
but it also became a game of being in
the right place at the right time with
my hands
and
playing along rhythmically this sort of
became the thing so i did a number of
weeks with a a teacher in la and then
went to barcelona and then the the
person who ultimately was my hand double
in the film also was my teacher there
and so
the cool thing about production again
being so specifically linked to those
moments of music so specifically is that
on the call sheet every day we would
have
images from the animatic along with what
bar of music that it corresponded to so
i could really specifically like learn
those parts
and you know it would stretch anywhere
from
5 to 20 seconds or 30 seconds so
it it then became really specific about
okay we're doing this bit let's learn
this and get this right um which was
super helpful as opposed to biting off a
massive amount however
los angeles from
the moment it starts
for the first
i'd have to look at the film to remember
exactly but it stays on me for a very
long time
tom you hear me
tom
you're playing beautifully dumb you're
playing great
but you need to ease up tom
you hear me ease up
you're gonna tire out your fingers
so the first part of that song i really
i had to learn ish
uh pretty well and it doesn't i mean
that's me like
playing along to it um
but anyway it's
the way that that is constructed is a
really good mixture of ultimately there
was definitely a hand double for some
close-up shots to sell it really well
there's a specific shot i remember
actually that was a it was a track
around the piano
that was constantly rotating so for bits
it would cover me and my hands talking
at the same time and that was like
patting your head and rubbing your belly
it was so
like my brain was doing this like i
can't isn't this what you wanted
you said yourself she was a muddler
muddling your whole life it seems
you don't know anything but i do tom
she might get more magazine covers than
you but you out of person of a note
she won't be in the history books he
will
and i'm hearing
because cusack was with us for a week
and
wasn't with us the rest of the times
because he was only on camera for x
amount of scenes the rest of time he's
in my ear so he recorded all of the
dialogue
of his conversations with me through the
earpiece prior
so when he was gone all that we did the
entire concert without him and so i'm
hearing audio of him talking as well as
the audio of the music simultaneously
having to keep that
going wiltst then hearing him and sp
yeah dude so hard
thankfully that only had to happen a
couple of times
come to death
at timson as a dear friend producer
kiwi
i had worked with ant actually we had we
had produced a movie together so ant
sent me the script
as a friend and was like hey
i i kind of have you in mind for this
would you read this
and i read it
and fell in love with it immediately
it it still remains sort of one of the
most
taught
surprising scripts i've ever read it
kept going places that i didn't
anticipate it going i just didn't see it
coming
and so many threads that are introduced
are paid off in
a really beautiful way it's just a very
taut genre exercise that starts as one
thing and ends as another thing and i
was
all in and then the character norvel
is
and it's funny because he sent me an
email with the script and then also a
picture of skrillex
he said this is the character
i was like okay
so his imagine you know and and skrillex
is i've met him he's a very nice guy but
but the idea of normal is that he's
meant to be a douchebag skrillex is not
um he's meant to be this sort of like
idj and um you know
i'm an influencer
big in music and
you know also has terrible fashion sense
but thinks he has amazing fashion sense
and he's sort of this like amalgam oh
all these ideas
which was really fun to play his
hairstyle is insane
ant's impulses i have to say initially
we're like
well we gotta reign this in because
there's a fine line with a character
like that of he has to be at some point
relatable because what he goes through
is intense and harrowing and you have to
you can't hate him you know you have to
like have a little disdain for him but
you also have to see his vulnerabilities
and ultimately you have to care about
him so it was really important to me to
find that balance of like douchiness and
ridiculousness
wilts also believing that it exists in
the real world somehow and is somewhat
grounded
which was a process of discovery and it
was really fun um
we shot in in uh we shot it up in
vancouver island and a small town called
tofino um and yeah the wardrobe was the
thing that we found with the costume
designer and tried a bunch of different
things
um
and yeah the hair the hair was
was awesome and i was all in i think
what's really fun about those kinds of
opportunities is to just
dive in and sort of uh
yeah like
don't don't toe dip like go for it and
we did and yeah the mustache is rad
norvel's
and normal's like a sad little guy you
know the thing about norvel 2 is he's
you know he's been estranged from his
father since he was five ultimately the
story is about a man reuniting with his
father for the first time since he was a
toddler basically
and so
you know
there's that heart and anticipation and
then there's this sort of expression of
douchiness and then it takes
a whole other
turn
no man of god
it sort of feels like a play a little
it's based on true events and true
meetings um it's based on the
recollections and transcripts in some
cases of these interviews and
conversations that bill hagmeyer the fbi
agent had with ted bundy in the last
four years prior to his execution it is
an exploration of that psyche of what it
takes to be that person um
it was it's a fascinating story i didn't
know you know i've known i've read a lot
about ted bundy and others over the
years um just out of
morbid fascination
but never knew this story i didn't know
about hagmeyer i didn't know about
the fact that you know
uh bundy considered him his best friend
and willed his last earthly possessions
to him
that he considered him that much of a
friend that he willed everything to
build at the end of his life
uh which bill did not accept uh
ultimately with understandable reasons
so that's a fascinating thing that that
this man
you know considered an fbi agent his
best friend and confidant now bill
wouldn't consider the same of ted
but that's sort of at the core of the
story um
you know there's a kind of central
thesis to the movie which is this idea
of
ted being fascinated with the notion
that anyone could be capable of doing
what he does
that he's not crazy um and i think
that's a defense mechanism certainly uh
and
a sort of you know the expression of a
man that's facing his death
ultimately
and so for for bill it's also about you
know whether or not he thinks he could
with that question um and just sort of
going through this process and
and ultimately
you know there's a part of that job
which is to gain information and
understanding
and that's really what he was there for
and in the midst of all of that
there is a human connection that happens
and i think that's at the core of the
film as well and i think
one of the things that's most
fascinating because
you know
yeah i suppose you know you could call
him a monster and he did monstrous
things at the end of the day he was a
flawed [ __ ] up human
and there were two human beings that had
a human connection you know
and that that that's just fascinating so
it's just
there's there's been so many
characterizations of bundy over the
years so many different amazing
documentaries um and and films and this
was just a different story that i think
really fascinated and sort of
um haunted us you know